en cette semaine pour l'emploi des
personnes handicapées marie-arlette
carlotti ministre délégué en charge des
personnes handicapées s'est rendu
aujourd'hui à elancourt au sein de
l'entreprise thales mais j'ai vu une
entreprise où il y avait véritablement
une volonté claire affirmé depuis 20 ans
d'intégrer les personnes en situation de
handicap comme des travailleurs
ordinaires avec leurs difficultés avec
intégré garder dans l'emploi maintenir
dans l'emploi quand il s'agit de
salariés qu'il est arrivé problèmes de
maladies ou garder dans l'emploi depuis
20 ans le groupe thales mène une
politique d'insertion à l'égard des
personnes en situation de handicap
aujourd'hui le taux global d'emplois
réservés aux personnes handicapées
s'élève à 5,1 pour cent et concerne 1640
salariés le groupe espère atteindre
d'ici à la fin de l'année le taux
minimal de 6 % imposée par l'état
il est important que cette compétence
elle reste dans dans l'entreprise et
c'est pas parce que c'est une personne
handicapée qu'elle ne doit pas avoir une
évolution de carrière comme les autres
afin qu'on puisse garder aussi cette
compétence est donc c'est en mettant en
place et ses politiques de maintien dans
l'emploi donc accompagnement adaptation
des postes de travail innovation
technologique aussi pour permettre de
mettre en place des moyens techniques
pour compenser le handicap
et puis des formations appropriées qu'on
arrive à maintenir dans l'emploi des
personnes handicapées
à l'exemple de ses salariés qui
bénéficient d'une aide technique pour
leur permettre de mieux voir ou de
communiquer par téléphone malgré un
handicap auditif
vous le savez
le président de la république qui va
s'exprimer tout à l'heure le premier
ministre a comme objectif l'emploi
l'emploi est toujours l'emploi
on parle beaucoup du rééquilibrage des
comptes publics la situation compliquée
c'est vrai que c'est pas quelque chose
qui fait rêver mais derrière ça nous
n'oublions pas notre objectif
la justice la solidarité et ça passe par
l'emploi et ça passe par l'emploi des
personnes en situation de handicap le
président république de sa campagne a
dit qu'il augmenterait les sanctions des
entreprises qui ne répondent pas aux
critères de la loi
mais pour y remédier en même temps qu
augmenter les sanctions
on va d'abord discuter et c'est bien ce
qu'on va faire en 2013 lors d'une vraie
négociation avec l'ensemble des
partenaires autour de la table
de son côté l'ump a lancé une pétition
visant à accorder un prêt à taux zéro
pour les personnes souffrant d'un
handicap moteur
la proposition de loi menée par gérald
darmanin et l'illinois david douillet
est déjà soutenue par 103 députés